just before the break you heard the
founder of blackwater eric prince
remember the time that his men rescued
joe biden and john kerry from taliban
controlled afghanistan but the
conversation was much deeper than that
for a brand new episode of tucker
carlson today prince joined us on set
and gave us perspective on what is
happening in afghanistan now
why it happened and what it tells us
about the leadership of this country
here's part of the conversation
[Music]
what effects does this have since i mean
you've worked in a lot of different
countries and likely still are um
what effect is this going to have
on the rest of the world i mean there
are pretty clear lessons from this are
there not i think much more than
the democrats ever complaining about
trump damaging nato this will destroy
what's what's left of nato because the
u.s has been so unilateral and so
clueless
that mean for for the present united
states to be rebuked in the house of
parliament that's the first time it's
ever happened
um
so we have shattered the confidence of
our european allies and every other ally
around the world that america depends
whether you're a cia agent trying to
recruit somebody to work for you
or whether you're a country that wants
to that america wants you to compete
with you know to side with us versus
something that the chinese want
it will it will definitely figure into
people's thinking how quickly america
abandoned its friends in afghanistan and
left in such a horribly
chaotic and clumsy manner
and so there are going to be
permutations uh in all sides that we
haven't even thought of yet that come
from this because look the dollar
is the world's reserve currency correct
why because it's underpinned by the the
notion of u.s military strength
and what we're seeing unfold in
afghanistan over the last 20 years
and over the the last few weeks and the
next two weeks
really does not show well i i'd called
you know three years ago let's prevent
the helicopter off the rooftop moment in
saigon that's exactly what we got
so you mentioned our status as the
holder of the world's reserve currency
so that is central to our economy as we
central economy because we we deficit
spend and we can keep doing that because
because we can just print more and more
dollars when people
don't regard the united states as the
sole
as the pax americana goes away right and
they don't have the confidence of the
dollar that has massive uh triple down
implications to our um to our economy
and to our way of life
no reserve currency collapse of american
economy total reset in our standard of
living
completely different countries so we
have to live in our within our means
yeah right so that's not we're not
capable of doing the abolition of the
welfare state i mean
massive massive changes far greater
convulsions than the great depression or
any other
um
civil unrest we've had in america so i
guess the bigger point you're making is
that when the country in control of the
world reveals itself is weak
the world becomes much more volatile
when it reveals that it's defeated by
people using 70 year old weapons that
are living in a mindset of the 6th
century
that uh maybe that us military is not
quite as capable as they espouse
themselves to be maybe as as the as the
cosplay people describe itself to be you
know total inflammation awareness i
don't care how much surveillance you
have
what does it do to the reality of the
people on the ground
you just heard uh
lloyd austin the former
defense contractor now running the
department of defense that the real
threat he would like to remind all of us
as white supremacy in the united states
it sounds like maybe there's a shift
having been defeated by the taliban to
the real enemy here at home do you worry
about that
well i i find it amazing how worried
everyone in america is about kovid that
the taliban managed to conquer the
entire country without wearing masks and
didn't seem to uh to slow them down too
much so again i i think um
uh let's worry about the the big threats
and uh yes kobe can be taken seriously
but we don't need to shut down the
economy
the the american economy the machine
people have to get back to work and back
to school and keep on living
eric prince
one of the most knowledgeable people in
the world on the subject of afghanistan
that full conversation is on
foxnation.com
tucker carlson today hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else